[Music]
this is a picture of my family from 20
years ago I know you're thinking I was a
super cute kid
my mom is an incredible chef every time
I go home she makes all of my favorites
from spring rolls to roasted pork ever
since I can remember my family eats
dinner together every single night you
see my parents wanted some consistency
in our lives we moved six times before I
turned the age of 12 and as a shy kid I
had a hard time speaking up in class it
was a different story at the dinner
table though over the years I made a
number of updates such as how I got the
leading role of John Adams yes John
Adams in the fifth grade school play to
explain to them what prom was and as the
years went by my parents also gave their
own updates my parents talked about how
it was really difficult for them to
immigrate to the United States having to
leave our grandparents behind and my
brother also talked about how middle
school was tough and bullies they were
the worst we would eat talk and
reconnect time slowed down for us and it
was my favorite part of the day
consistent family dinners have numerous
benefits but as I think about the way
that we eat meals now it makes me wonder
if this timeless tradition is
disappearing as future leaders and
future parents it is our responsibility
to save this art the Bennet is a family
dinner have been studied for decades
Columbia University found that children
who ate at least 5 times that their
parents were more likely to do well in
school and 4 times less likely to smoke
what they also found was that these same
kids were more likely to say that their
parents were proud of them that their
parents are the people that they confide
to in just 30 minutes a day parents were
able to foster stronger relationships
with their parents
how many of you in this room are current
parents or wants me parents in the
future but most of the room what's the
problem we have to eat anyways so why
not eat together and even if you don't
have a family just yet you can go home
to your parents to your roommates to
your loved ones your chosen family the
problem though is that the way that we
eat meals now contrasts with the
fundamentals of a family dinner and
there are three reasons why the first is
that were you stating alone now dinner
has become a nutritional transaction we
can door - anything we want have it in
30 minutes and eat it on our couch alone
in fact 50% of meals are now eaten alone
I get it it's been a long day all you
want to do is relax
but our meals the time for us to do so
and when we have families well we all
eat alone so that we can recharge
independently it's not just eating alone
though distractions are now everywhere
smartphones have given us access to
information in seconds but they've also
given us an excuse not to engage with
one another having to post as
Millennials what does mealtime mean to
you and we responded with it's a time to
multitask we can watch Netflix we can
catch up on emails a family dinner
requires that all of us are present if
you're not there to talk about something
you're there to listen and to support
how can we do that if we're constantly
glued to our devices and if that wasn't
enough
work-life balance is just hard to
achieve nowadays I mean we're in Silicon
Valley we all know - all the perks of
working at our neighborhood tech company
three cot meals a day on the limited
snack bars from that weekly road warrior
to that employee who stays just a little
bit longer to squeeze out that extra
meal and do a little bit more work
our jobs have a way of influencing how
we end our days
I mean we're individuals now so we can
make that decision but what happens when
we have families will you be willing to
leave on time every single night to get
home to your family so you can have
dinner together every generation wants
more more time more speed more
convenience
how will we defend the family dinner I'm
looking at the answer right now I'm
looking at future leaders as we've seen
policies can have really great benefits
but a lot of unintended side effects
when uber was reviewed by Eric Holder
one of the first things that he changed
was he moved up the company catered
dinner time from 8:15 to 7:00 p.m. he
wanted it to signal the end of the day
YouTube CEO makes it a point to have
dinner with her family every single
night she says I try because if I can
make it home for dinner I can get the
scoop for my kids on their day we have
policies like maternity leave and
paternity leave for new parents we
should also have policies that promote
family time when those new parents
return to work as future leaders we have
the opportunity to prioritize family
dinners within our organizations so
let's do it with intention
you're not just future leaders though
you're also future parents Aaron's set
the traditions at the family dinner
table
Time magazine did a study where they
compared those with devices at the table
to those without devices those devices
they enjoyed their meals more less
distracted and more engaged my mom
worked a full-time job and she commuted
three hours a day to make ends meet for
us yet every night when she came home we
ate dinner together without distractions
I am forever grateful to her for that
and I want to see a family dinner at
every single table
I was reading a magazine a few weeks ago
and I came across this quote to eat is a
necessity but to eat intelligently is an
art what does he mean by intelligently
the dakedo thing for me to eat
intelligently is to move beyond eating
alone to actually gathering at the table
to move beyond our everyday distractions
and to being present for one another to
move beyond just having a meal to having
a conversation for me to eat is a
necessity but to eat together is an art
I recently returned home for the
holidays and like clockwork
at 6:30 my parents called us down for
dinner as you can see my mom still makes
all of my favorite dishes over our meal
remember that told us how he had been
selected to be in a recruiting video at
work my parents asked us when we could
take our family portraits together
I shared but I would be giving this
low-key know the clinking of the dishes
my brothers cackling laughs i sat there
and bliss so happy to be home let's
bring dinner back where it belongs
together and at the table
[Applause]
[Music]